our next guest is a tick tock star who
has gained a massive following because
of the relatable way that she discusses
women's health issues and today she's
joining us to share her gut reaction on
how we can all improve our gut health
it's so true it's such a north star of
our bodies please welcome registered
dietitian and intuitive eating counselor
with find food freedom sam private
i'm so excited to talk with you
i'm so excited to also learn from you
like oh god i fear this question
because i fear the answer
what contributes to poor gut health in
women
well i hope that my answer makes you
happy because where i like to start with
women is our relationship with food oh
dear so i invite i invite all my clients
to look at what is your relationship
with food is it stressful is it peaceful
if it is stressful thinking about okay
how much time are we spending counting
calories macros portioning out food
cutting out entire food groups how many
years have we spent yo-yo dieting
and if we notice that we're stressing a
lot about that we can repair that
relationship with food and so that's a
big part of what we do at fine food
freedom is
help our clients really make peace with
food remove the morality from food
remove the guilt and shame guilt and
shame should never be an ingredient on
the plate so how do we help our guts
grow stronger
um
and sort of really aid in our wellness
yes so i am a huge proponent of
inclusion
not restriction so thinking about okay
let's bring it back to the basics right
what are the three things that keep us
alive and thriving and functioning sleep
water food right so sleep hygiene
seven to nine hours a night if possible
now i'm 35 weeks pregnant so if i can
get your 35 weeks if i can get two oh my
god you should have seen me at 35 weeks
i was like
when drew barrymore asked you to fly to
new york you come to oh my god but
you're the obviously the walking pillar
of health this is i mean really you
should have seen me at 35 weeks i
whoa so when we have to think about
water too right like water is found in
every single cell in the body it helps
transport nutrients digestion absorption
and then once we get that water intake
and thinking about food are we getting
enough fuel throughout the day so
commonly people are under fueling
and what kind of food are we getting can
we get nutrient dense foods that will
help heal that gut microbiome and really
give us that good bacteria
but i also think that there are things
out there that can help aid in gut
health and digestion
and
those are really important and we've
teamed up with a line probiotics and
you're a big proponent of their products
especially for women may i ask why
yes so once we heal that relationship
with food right and we remove the guilt
and shame we have our nutrient dense
foods we can absolutely add that
probiotic supplement and we mentioned
tick tock earlier all social media
there's a lot of misinformation out
there especially if you look up like
gut health so i'm a huge fan of brands
like align that i can really trust that
are backed by research yes and they have
a team of female scientists that have
really
gotten together talked with women and
said okay how do we create this product
that's going to contribute to not only
digestive gut health but also feminine
health and mood balance i was going to
say it must be quite different for a
woman's body and a man's body
so it's nice when you feel as a woman
because i want men to have their backs
taken care of and it is nice when
there's because boy our bodies are
really complex look at what they're
capable of doing yes it's so beautiful
women's bodies are so unique and so
align did such a great job of creating
this dual action probiotic to really
touch on all aspects of health that's
just a really really healthy attitude
for you to convey to everybody so thank
you for that messaging
and thank you for the tips
[Music]